[Music]
michael is with us michael's in la hey
michael welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and john how's it going good
man how can we help
yeah so um i'm 24 years old um i make
170 000 a year
uh i mean you know the company i work
for is great you know culture's great
everything about it's great work 24 and
you make 170 a year what do you do
so i work in fulfillment and logistics
what do you fulfill
no he legit
oh
so yeah supply chain
yes exactly exactly so a lot of like
e-commerce um
uh yeah basically like qvc is is a
problem you are aware that you are
unicorn right
uh i i guess so sir 24 year olds that
make 170 000 a year do not grow on trees
dude
that's very impressive very impressive
you must be very very good at what you
do that's incredible
thank you thank you so much it's an
honor coming from you guys
um so yeah let me come up with the
problem so you know all my life i feel
like i'm still searching like for more
and more i'm great at my job
but i feel like i can do more
i'm gonna know what culture these days
company culture at least you know
i'm afraid of like leaving my company
um you know i've only been here for
eight months
but before this
this role
i was doing the same exact level same
i'm a director level uh currently right
now
and and i feel like i could become a vp
level you know in the next you know six
months and
i just wanted some guidance you know am
i being too confident am i being too
hasty you know i feel like i want more i
feel like i want a larger scope i feel
like i want to do
um you know be even better than i am
right now um am i wrong for for feeling
that way or looking to leave my company
within like six months
i
you're conflating a lot of things into a
single stream
right
why do you want to be a vice president
no larger scope
why do you want to have larger scope
i feel like i want to do more i want to
make more changes i want to
why
like what
what will you get
you want to make more changes what does
that mean
like like i i want like i guess the
question would why would anyone want a
better paying job or why would anyone
more okay here work to do like i want to
learn that's a great question okay yes
in learning more that's just you
conflated a lot
here's a you're 24 so here's a powerful
life lesson if you can learn this at 24
i didn't get it until i was probably 37
or 38
and it was a humbling smack in my face
okay
whatever job you get whatever person you
get to marry you whatever car you buy
whatever kid you have the second kid
third kid eighth kid
you go with you
and so that stirring you have that
feeling that sense of i'm just not i'm
i'm just not complete i'm just not
that's gonna go to your next job and
you're gonna get vice president and
you're gonna be within six months you'll
be thinking
okay uh where can i be ceo and then i
want to be a ceo
it's you're going to keep running and
running and running until you decide
you're all right where you are and i'm
going to learn this stuff now here's the
other side to that
we need really really ambitious peach
people in our culture right now we get a
lot of big problems that we need fixed
you by the way fix the supply chain what
are you doing they're paying you 170
grand and
there's a lot of big problems so i want
people to be ambitious i want people to
start businesses and work really hard
and grow big businesses to help a lot of
the challenges in the country i just
want the leaders and those companies to
know
that
those big paychecks and that vice
presidency it's not going to fix you
it's not going to make you feel less
restless and you sound a lot like me who
the moment i got a job i was applying
for the other job and then as soon as i
got that job i was thinking about where
am i going to go next
and it wasn't until i landed and said
i got to fix my relationships with
myself
with my past with my family with my
friends and then i have this state of
peace and here's what's beautiful about
it
then i could go do anything
and then i ended up in the job of a
lifetime and after that i got the job of
another lifetime after that right you
see what i'm saying
you're right that makes total sense what
you're chasing is peace and you will not
get that in a job title or a dollar
amount yeah shut up
going back go ahead going back to your
first um wait do you want to talk dave
sorry you're fine go ahead
okay going back to your first thing like
like is it wrong like for example i
won't find peace and i'll make it to vp
and then see all one day but is that
wrong to like like is it wrong to
realize that i need peace at the ceo
level like oh like
you're right i need peace but oh i'm the
ceo making 250 a year like like is that
wrong to like go as a stylist you're
attaching a moral construct
to to to a linear condition
all right now what i mean is that okay
this okay
ambition is not wrong
growth is not wrong
changing jobs is not wrong
doing it to try to become complete
because you weren't complete at the last
place
is bad medicine
it's not going to work in other words
john john as a talk he does says the
title of the talk is winning doesn't
make you well
right so you sound very smart and very
legitimately not illegitimately
ambitious
but the fact that you're struggling with
the part of you that's struggling with
is this wrong as if it's a moral
construct that it's bad to be ambitious
or it's bad to have growth or it's bad
to make a big income or it's bad to move
up the ladder it's bad to change jobs
none of those things are bad none of
them are good
they're ambivalent to the moral
construct
but ambition for ambition's sake
ambition so that i feel good about the
guy in the mirror
you won't ever catch him he keeps moving
he's a bully in the schoolyard he takes
another step back draws another line the
sand says when you step across this line
then you'll be happy and then when you
step across this line then you'll be
happy and then when you step across this
line then you'll be happy and happiness
is not aligned across
right
and so it's not bad nothing you have
done
physically morally
is in a moral construct that is bad it's
all good
why you're doing some of it maybe i'm
going to guess john is listening to you
michael my estimate would be that 20 of
why you're doing this
is brokenness 80 is all good reasons
right but you're piling them all in
together and the brokenness part is
making you question the whole idea so
let me let me tell you a shape-shifter
in my career i got a job way over my
head at a real young age very much like
you i was pretty good at what i did um
and they took care of me and it wasn't
until i got around people that were one
step ahead of me the vice presidents
and then i realized oh they know this
stuff really well they had something i
didn't have we all had knowledge they
had wisdom
i'd love to see you stay put for a year
for two years and learn the business and
not just how logistics work but how
people work and how the cycle is going
to work through a recession and and get
some of that wisdom some of those scars
and strength and then you will be an
incredible vice president you go into
that stuff with confidence wisdom and
peace
you are you're an incredible young guy
don't look for healing in movement
it's not there
this is the ramsey show